[Music]  Kim Kardashian goes Loco over  unflattering paparazzi shots from her  Mexican vacation in a sneak peak from  this Sunday's all-new episode of Keeping  Up with the Kardashians they always keep  it crazy the 36 year old reality star  freaks out after her assistant Stephanie  Shepard discovers the paps have been  snapping photos of the girls during  their birthday getaway for Kourtney  I'm Marty having this anxiety attack  over security and I'm Marty just like on  high alert and now paparazzi has found  us it's like just the scrutiny that we  get all the time we try to avoid that  Kim of course increased security after  getting robbed in her Paris hotel room  last year but it's not a new thing for  the mom of two to take measures to  protect yourself from the pack I mean  just our home has full-time security  everywhere we travel with security I  used to like to go everywhere the mall  places just without security and I think  you know at some point just for safety  it helped